JOANNA SMITH: Hi.
I'm Joanna Smith,
and today we'll
look at how Stream Analytics
from a Google Cloud
helps bring the real-time
e-commerce experience to life.
Real-time data is
unique in that it
provides an opportunity
for businesses
to react without delay.
Valuable events, such as
an online shopper clicking
on an item's
details, can trigger
dynamic and
immediate experiences
on a website or mobile app.
The opportunity to generate
value around this data type
is only growing.
In fact, the International
Data Corporation
estimates that within five
years, more than a quarter
of all data globally will
be real-time in nature.
But for an application to
react to real-time data,
it's crucial to have
data analysis, insights,
and actions that occur
without human intervention.
Stream Analytics does just
that, offering automated
real-time data analysis.
Let's take a look.
Here, we've got our
e-commerce site, Newkicks.
And on the right
throughout this demo,
you'll see some
context on what's
happening behind the
JavaScript on the GCP platform.
Let's take a look at
how Stream Analytics
can improve the Newkicks
shopping experience
and drive sales.
We've used Pub/Sub, Dataflow,
BigQuery and Bigtable
to create the data streams
that will allow Newkicks
to make their data actionable
within milliseconds
of being generated.
For example, the hot item
flag is created in real time,
as Pub/Sub ingests user
clicks throughout the site
to be processed by Dataflow,
allowing Newkicks to determine
which products are
currently being
viewed by at least 50 people.
When our shopper
clicks on an item,
they see that there
are 62 people looking
at these exact shoes
at this moment.
Our shopper adds the
shoes to their cart
and immediately sees
a low inventory alert
powered by data from
the inventory stream,
and based on real-time stock
availability information.
To reliably offer this type
of shopping experience,
even during busy times, Newkicks
relies on Pub/Sub's ability
to ingest millions
of events per second,
combined with Dataflow's
exactly-once processing
with fault tolerance.
If a user misses their
opportunity window
and the shoes
become out of stock,
real-time AI can turn a
frustrating user moment
into a seamless exchange,
with a personalized product
replacement suggestion.
In parallel, this
inventory insight
also enables Newkicks to trigger
a back-end stock replenish
process.
Our shopper liked the
alternative shoes,
and when checking out is
offered a chance to pick them up
in a nearby store.
Here Newkicks uses real time
inventory and transactional
data from the local stores
to offer the user a chance
to get their shoes faster.
Real-time data enabled
Newkicks to act, and react,
to create a positive
purchase experience.
That's one more happy customer.
Now let's take a look at how
this works within the Google
Cloud platform.
Real-time data is generated
based on certain events,
like user interactions.
So the first step is
to configure an event
to push to Pub/Sub,
which will serve
as a trigger for a
particular data stream.
To create that
data stream, start
by defining a topic in Pub/Sub.
With Stackdriver, we can
see high-level summaries
for our Pub/Sub activity.
Here we have the rate
of incoming messages
for all three of
Newkicks' data streams.
The message volume
comes in bursts,
based on the day of the
week or the time of day.
Our demo peaks at around
200-300 messages per second,
but could scale to
thousands, or even
millions of events per
second without anyone
having to change a thing.
No planning necessary,
because Pub/Sub
is a fully-managed
service that automatically
scales to what's needed.
Another interesting
summary is the oldest,
unacknowledged message
within any topic.
Here we can see they
are being picked up
just a few seconds after
being pushed into Pub/Sub.
And with this
monitoring system, we
can set up alerts to
send out notifications
if values extend
beyond our SLOs.
After the data is ingested,
it needs to be processed.
And this is where
Dataflow takes over.
By establishing
Dataflow pipelines,
those initial events can trigger
application behaviors, business
logic, or even additional
processing steps.
These pipelines run on
the flexible, open source,
Apache Beam SDK.
They were built
programmatically,
using Dataflow's wide variety
of supported programming
languages, including Java,
Python, and the recent addition
of SQL, with more set to come.
In Stackdriver we can see
graphs of the rate of processing
for Dataflow, but let's
take a deeper look
at how we actually
process that data.
In the Dataflow
monitoring graph,
we can explore each
of the three streaming
pipelines we saw for
Newkicks-- click, inventory,
and transactional.
On this page, we see various
statistics for the pipeline.
CPU, throughput, et cetera.
But for a closer look at what
the pipeline is actually doing,
let's change tabs.
Now we can see the
processing pipeline.
There are three sources of
data, each being processed
independently, before
joining together
for cross-stream analytics.
From data validation
and correction
to flattening and
formatting, all of this
is happening in real
time, rather than
through a series of
batch-processing steps.
Interestingly, some pipelines
pull data from a Pub/Sub sink
and land right back in
Pub/Sub for the next stage
of processing.
This is one of the core
promises of Stream Analytics,
joining the data analytics
processing system directly
to the operational systems.
Once processed, our data
moves to either Bigtable,
for low-latency,
high-concurrency availability
back to the Newkicks
website, or to BigQuery,
for deeper analytics.
We saw how Newkicks
applied these data streams
within their website.
So now let's take a look at
what happens in BigQuery.
In the BigQuery user
interface, the data
sets this user can access
are listed on the left.
And we can choose to look
at the click-stream table
under the retail data site.
We can see it has about
118 million rows of data,
and that it is
auto-partitioned by time
using the timestamp column.
Additionally, right here
within the BigQuery web UI,
users have the ability
to write and run
SQL queries against both
Dataflow, for further ease
and flexibility of pipeline
creation, and BigQuery.
We've already seen
Dataflow in action.
So let's run a query against
the fresh data in BigQuery,
say the last 10 minutes.
We can also run
more complex queries
like this one, which merges our
click-stream and transactional
data streams to output
popular sales items sold
online in the last 10
minutes, versus in-store
in the last hour.
The power of Stream Analytics
is that the entire process,
from the first event trigger
to your application reacting,
is entirely hands off.
Once you set up
your data stream,
the auto-scaling capabilities
of Pub/Sub and Dataflow
help ensure that the entire
interaction keeps working, even
at the busiest moments.
But when you do want
to take a deeper look,
dashboards for
real-time data and data
streams are still classic.
Let's take that closer look.
In Looker, we can
see visualizations
for data analysts supporting
real-time website activity.
For example, here we have our
purchase conversion funnel.
This data is updating with
an auto-refresh running
every minute.
Even though Stream Analytics
occur in real time,
dashboards like this allow
you to review performance
in order to glean insights
and optimize for the future.
Looker consumes and
aggregates real-time data
streams to help Newkicks
determine things
like where in the
purchasing process
a user is most
likely to abandon,
or whether a hot item
flags perform best
when set to display for products
with greater than 50 viewers,
or greater than 100 viewers.
And that is how Steam
Analytics from Google Cloud,
built on the auto-scaling
infrastructure of Pub/Sub,
Dataflow and
BigQuery, helps bring
to life the real-time
e-commerce experience.
Check the documentation to learn
more, and thanks for watching.